heureusement pas
[Musique]
a nancy
allez venez l'eau est parfaite
[Musique]
monsieur craig j'ai commencé la semaine
dernière j'aimerais me présenter je sais
qui vous êtes ce brune battant qui est
un avenir brillant devant elle vous avez
eu des débuts difficiles
[Musique]
alors ne laissez jamais personne vous
rendre aux deux de votre passé
tient enfin sentiment que la vie me mène
quelque part dans la bonne direction moi
aussi
votre villa est vraiment magnifique
merci alors vous cherchez un verre ma
femme est très fier de ses cocktails
voici claire mam nouvelle assistante
clair ma femme
[Musique]
est ce que je peux savoir ce qui se
passe ce matin dans la chambre de
monsieur craignent une femme de ménage a
découvert des éléments qui pourrait
faire penser à un homicide a des traces
de sang des signes de lutte
la dernière fois que vous l'avez vu
c'était quand on s'est aperçu que ce
n'est pas exactement la première fois
que vous avez à faire la police
j'ai vu ses relevés bancaires elle met
de l'argent de côté depuis des années de
parler de notre relation et marine ont
quelqu'un l'a fait là tu deviens parano
en a plus rien à cacher
y ont à l'arme du crime
ces derniers détails à régler
[Musique]
dumas piégée
et en sécurité ici
et je suis en sécurité nulle part
[Musique]